about 3.5 billion years ago
single-celled organisms were the only
life-forms that existed on earth these
organisms passed on their genetic
material with slight changes to their
descendants
and over long periods of time these
genetic changes resulted in new species
and eventually the vast diversity of
modern organisms evolves some organisms
share a more recent common ancestor than
others do
scientists have found evidence that we
humans are more closely related to
chimpanzees than we are to rabbits and
we're more closely related to rabbits
than we are to sharks and you might be
wondering how can scientists determine
how closely two species are related to
each other
asking a shark hey do you think we
shared a common ancestor 440 million
years ago doesn't help because even if
they spoke english they probably
wouldn't know the answer either
scientists analyzed the similarities and
differences between species to help
figure out how they might be related in
evolutionary history
and they found significant evidence for
evolution by using a variety of methods
including examining the fossil record
analyzing the dna of different organisms
and comparing the development of embryos
which are what organisms are called
before they're born
however you don't need a microscope or a
fossil to find evidence for evolution
you can find it by looking at the
anatomical or physical features of
organisms alive today one way that
scientists use information from the
present day to make sense of past
evolutionary relationships is by
searching for clues called homologous
features when two species share a
structurally similar anatomical feature
that they inherited from a common
ancestor we say that the feature is
homologous
the word homologous begins with a latin
prefix meaning the same
and this makes sense because when two
species have homologous features it
means they share the same ancestor have
you ever looked at an x-ray of a human's
arm if you have you might have noticed
that we have humerus ulna radius carpals
and metacarpal bones
if you looked at the skeleton of a
bird's wing you could see that birds
have a similar bone structure to ours in
fact this similar bone structure appears
in the forelimbs of many other animals
including dogs cats whales elephants and
bats these animals can use these
features in different ways to fly to run
to swim or to wave hello but despite
these differences in function the
similarities of the bone structure
indicate that these species inherited
these features from a common ancestor
this means that the bone structure is a
homologous feature compared to species
with few similarities two species that
share many homologous features are
likely to be more closely related which
means that they are likely to share a
more recent common ancestor species with
fewer homologous features are likely to
be less closely related which means that
they are likely to share a more distant
common ancestor for example the wing of
this bird has more structural
similarities to the leg of this lizard
than to the wing of the spat this
indicates that the bird is more closely
related to the lizard than it is to the
bat which means that the bird and the
lizard share a more recent common
ancestor than the bird and the bat do
with scientists believe they have found
species with homologous features they
can use other methods to find out more
about how the species evolved over time
they can compare the anatomical features
of modern organisms to those found in
fossils to see how much they have in
common sometimes scientists find
features that seem to be homologous at
first glance but the features actually
evolved independently along different
species lineages these features are
called analogous features for example
let's take a look at the wings of two
flying creatures a bird and a butterfly
in order to figure out whether the wings
are homologous features we need to
examine the physical structure of the
wings the bird's wing is made up of
hollow bones while the butterfly's wing
is made up of membranes made out of a
protein called chitin so even the birds
and butterflies can both fly their wings
have very different structures this
means that bird wings and butterfly
wings are analogous features
this indicates the scientist that birds
and insects did not inherit that feature
from a common ancestor instead the
ability to fly using wings evolves
independently in each lineage
comparing the anatomical features of
organisms has given scientists a better
understanding of how life on earth has
evolved from common ancestors so next
time you meet a friendly shark perhaps
the two of you can bond over your shared
ancestry